roulés boulés dans la rosée du matin le
début d'une folle journée sur l'île
charlemagne la no limits course
d'obstacles pour petits et grands est
lancé courir grimper et ramper sauter
s'accrocher et surtout s'amuser
l'idée c'est de mon fils et sur 12 ha
c'est alexis qui m'a convaincu depuis
trois ans a offert ce genre d'épreuve
eh ben je remercie parce que franchement
c'est super ne vous y trompez pas ce
qu'ils sont là l'ont choisi à tort ou à
raison c'est selon
j'ai pas pu suivre le rythme de ma
petite fille ok là c'est agathe va trop
vite pour moi l'important c'est
d'arriver en famille ou entre amis les
départs s'enchaînent avec des
concurrents de poils au rail a pas de
technique logiciel un bon délai limite
cette équipe la formation tortue et en
avant pour battre
non pas les gaulois mais les romains je
suis un dissidente
permettez moi d'insister ceux qui sont
là l'ombre vraiment choisi elle est au
bout de ses limites
à défaut d'une problèmes de santé c'est
une franche partie de rigolade et la
météo n'aura rien gâcher
la pluie amène justement un peu plus de
joie dans le temps si dans tous les cas
on va être dans la boue trompé et c'est
ce qu'on vient chercher c'est la
difficulté maintenant ça donnera c'est
pas bien c'est pas mieux à la fin alors
on est fatigué on a tout donné
non c'était bien franchement pour
l'année prochaine